I apologize I've said your name
incorrectly I think two times how dare
you I know but it's men Lucas and I know
it's it's Greek but I see that whenever
I see the 0uk I think I'm being correct
when I go back thousands yeah no you
you're not we're I mean it's it's said
just like it's spelled you know it's
just full of consonants with a Z in the
middle all right that is fun well I'm
loving the beard and I have to say you
have you you even you would admit that
you've had some great success with your
beard oh yeah you grew a beard a number
of years ago and suddenly you started
getting roles that you don't think you
would have gotten before
probably well probably not I had like I
went through like a horrible breakup and
decided to grow a beard as people do
when horrible things happen people do
that I've done that yeah I'm aware yeah
and so I grew this enormous beard and
and people were like this is weird you
look weird you look crazy cuz now it's
shorter now I'm doing a movie right now
where they want me to look like a normal
this is a beard of a guy who could work
in a law firm I'm listening yeah yeah I
like that yeah you have a nice shop okay
okay I approach the bench your honor yes
you may
great yeah but your beard has it I've
seen your gloriously on the league when
it's been out of control no no no super
super crazy and it was at like I at one
point like I you know I went to his
break up grew this giant beard and then
at a certain point it was like okay I
need to figure my out I need to get out
there and I started talking to this girl
at a party and was like yeah chit chat
chit chat and she was like and I asked
her out and she was like you know I'm
not gonna go out with you and I was like
oh why and she was like your beard tells
me that you're going through something
really crazy you have what my friends
and I call a mental illness B thing is
it's really happening
yeah she was like ya know you can you
can ask me out when you're ready to
shave that beard suffice to say we never
went out now because then I started
getting work with it which was great but
then also trapped me into a giant
crazy-looking beard right because once
you start getting the work you can't
take it off and once you look like a
monster everyone wants you to put them
on okay you also have your you can have
very intense eyes when you want to yeah
you you have a way of making your eyes
sort of pop in his fierce way and I've
seen when a lot of pictures of you with
fans yeah you're doing you seem to do it
intentionally with people yeah people
I'm always happy to take pictures with
people people are like hey can I get a
picture especially people who watch the
league and on the league I play like
like a sociopath like yeah like a truth
monster yeah yeah murderer
Rafi is a is a as a he's a sociopath
yeah I know like he's a horrible person
which is always funny to me because
people like you're my favorite character
and I'm like that says a lot about you
your favorite character the guy you
identify with is the guy that like is
capable of and is shown murdering people
on this very normal show about fantasy
football and so people come up to me and
are like oh you're my favorite character
can I get a picture and I'm always like
yeah sure of course and then I put my
arm around them and somebody's taking
the picture and then I'll go and then
I'll be smiling and then as they come in
I'll go these are just fans they have no
idea and I think we have another one
last one right here yeah they only find
out later on they check and oftentimes
the person taking the picture will
notice and they'll be they will start to
crack up and the person will be like
what what happened what happened and I'm
like I'll see you later good bye
you